many fans of baldur's gate three myself
included are hungry for more news so i'm
going to try and roll high on my
persuasion checks
and get some information out of larian's
own sven vinca sven how you doing hi
dave
very fine so how would you describe the
current state of baldur's gate
um every every time we're silent that
usually means we're busy with something
so we're busy with something uh it's
taking a little bit longer than we
expected
uh so uh but the next update is is
around the corner
uh i'm not gonna give you the exact date
because otherwise i would have to keep a
stick to it
uh but we're trying to push it out of
the door uh so
it's an update that focuses on a lot of
the feedback that we've been getting so
it's it's more focused on features than
it is on new content
uh but it's got a lot of new things in
there which i think
uh i hope are going to be well received
it certainly addresses
a bunch of the things that we've been
reading on reddit forums team community
forums and so forth
so that's pretty much what's going on so
the last major update was back in
february of this year with the druid
being added
um what has your team learned since then
so
there's obviously we are working on
what's in early access and we're also
working
on the rest of the game trying to get it
finished eventually at some point
big things that we're learning from
players
is on boarding is a big thing so we
we need to work harder on the onboarding
so we're doing a lot of stuff
uh some of it will actually be in the
next update also uh to
roll players into what is it like to
play what does advantage mean those kind
of things so
uh it's not just tutorials it's also
really
a whole a whole bunch of things there's
really a lot to it and by the time you
will see the finished game
you will see everything that we've done
in that direction and you'll understand
what i'm talking about so
i'm being a bit fake about it but cool
stuff so certainly
things that make the game better combat
remains a core focus
point for us we are getting feedback
that
certain players are not finding what
they're looking for so we're trying to
work on that trying stuff out a lot of
iterations a lot of
uh things that work don't work uh so
some of them are also coming that we're
we're adding
uh combat to dominantly the problem is
that the tabletop system certain things
don't translate well to the video game
uh so this is the bit that we are yeah
we're working on
we have a lot of ids but they take time
to try out uh
so um they're not that far off into the
future also for
us to release them on the community to
see what they think so based on this are
you making big changes to systems that
are already
in the game we are actually we
you can certainly expect uh certain
things to be turned around if you think
it's necessary if you see
players not finding themselves in there
the biggest problem we have right now
is we see a lot of players that focus on
the mini classes
and they don't have enough things to do
as they progress and that has
to a certain extent the limitation of
the video game is there because when
you're playing at the tabletop you can
come up with crazy ideas or your dm can
help you
figure out crazy ideas of things that
are beyond what you would be your basic
actions
uh and so putting that in the game
because we're
a company that focuses on systems so we
want everything that goes in there as a
system
it's not so easy uh so but it's
something that we're working on like
an example of a system that that does
work well
uh even for the military class is
actually even better for the mini
classes
would be shoving people right throwing
is also something that works well it's a
system you can throw pretty much
everything that you can see if you're
strong enough
etc uh so those things work well and
they augment
the action um choices that
that melee classes especially in the
beginning of the game because that's
where actually the poor problem lies
uh especially in the beginning uh it
gives them more things to do and we find
that a lot of players come here and they
they
often they've played original sin uh
they don't find the same type of game
playback and they want to have be able
to do more things than they would expect
than you can do in dnd uh and so we're
trying to figure out solutions to this
um
this is not a criticism of dnd the
fighter class is the tutorial class
so at the tabletop it is used to teach
you how to play
but as a result it gives you limited
things at the from the get-go
to to work with and modern audience is a
little bit our own fault because we
educated them like this with with
divinity uh expect to be able to do
things that matter very rapidly
and so we need to teach them this is not
that type of game it's different
uh but uh that doesn't mean that you
can't do really good stuff
and so we we have to figure out ways
of communicating that's because that's
why i mentioned onboarding also
there's a bunch of things that you can
actually do but that are not necessarily
clear and maybe with a little bit of
better
user experience you can fix those
so in terms of content being added to
the game can you give us any hints
whatsoever to what you're working on uh
uh yes it's going to be
more extensive than any of the things
that we've done so far
so there's going to be things that
people would expect that maybe not
necessarily part of the next update
uh are going to be coming down the line
eventually it takes a lot of time to
make these it's because we are getting
further and further in development
so we have much more things that we have
to take into account now as we add stuff
uh so it's a bit slower but we do have
things that are cooking which i think
will
uh will be very welcomed once we're
going to release them
so a little bit of patience is going to
be necessary there
um our project is lower than it used to
be
uh so we obviously like everybody else
and we've been affected by
uh by the crisis uh so but there's still
a lot of work being done there's a lot
of stuff happening
uh and when it's all going to land i
think it's going to
make the game a lot better
if you keep up with the pattern of each
update being bigger than the last you're
gonna
hit critical mass of what you can put
out at some point surely
that's when we'll release right
[Applause]
that's uh i mean like um we
we're really trying to to to get the
game done by next year
so i mean it's not going to release this
year for sure but we're we're working
very hard
on getting everything in there but it's
a very big game and it deserves to have
development time so
um and each every single feature um
there are features that you're going to
see in in the next update that you
didn't expect that you
say why are they doing this and then
when you'll play it you'll start
understanding oh this is why they're
doing it or maybe it'll tie into
something that comes later
but we're taking really a lot of time to
polish these features
for the two through qa already before we
release the community so
we already have our initial rounds of
feedback so that we really
when i guess in players hands we we when
we get the feedback hopefully it's good
and if it's something that we overlooked
we can still react to it and
there's a yeah it takes time
that's the only thing i can say it's
like you can't the cooking is slow
but there's a lot of meat that's really
good when you cook it for a very long
time
so in terms of boulder's gate 3 leaving
early access a full release
is 2020 just ballpark what you're aiming
for
we would be happy if we can manage to
release it next year yes i mean like
we're aiming for it
uh that's no guarantees uh so
but we're definitely aiming for it i
mean like we
took a big setback and especially in
everything that was related to motion
capture
and voice acting uh during the the
crisis so
that has taken time also teams working
together is harder
uh but now as uh slowly hopefully
the world is getting in a better place
uh we are starting to be able to pick up
speed again
and so uh yeah but we still have a lot
of work like
it's not as if we're done yet and yeah
it's a big game
on why i assume is a very long to-do
list when it comes to boulder's gate
three
last time we spoke we didn't have the
new generation of consoles in your hand
is bringing boulder's gate 3 to xbox
series x and ps5
something that you're working towards
you know after all
d20 on there i've got a d20 if you want
me to roll it
i can grab it right now should i give it
a go
[Music]
does a 19 hit right now
right now can you pass guidance i can't
i can't re-roll or anything i've got
i've got like a plus two
to persuasion does that help man okay i
wish you had our next update in your
hands already and you might have done
something about it
so the fans missing you in armor and you
usually bust one out for
big things like a panel from hell is
there a panel from hell
three in the works uh yeah i'm actually
dying to put it on again
uh it's 33 33 degrees celsius over here
so i guess that translates into
fahrenheit i don't know what
uh so yeah i mean like there's going to
be at some point
a new panel from hell uh so um
and uh yeah the plans that we have for
that one are very very special
so uh a big takeaway on this is like we
are it's not because we're silent that
we're not doing anything but we are
trying to focus on finishing stuff
and so that that typically comes with
some silence which is not
necessarily what community wants to hear
but it's the best way of doing things
otherwise you don't get them done
the difference between divinity original
sin 2 in early access
and then full release was mammoth
is that sort of going to be the same
vibe when it comes to baldur's gate
3's eventual release is it going to be
worlds different from what we've played
now is there going to be giant leaps
forward that we can
feel as players yes um
so i think there's two quantum jumps
that are going to be
the case with bg3 the first one is
people that started it up when they got
early access on day one
and so when they'll see it at release
they will be very surprised
because there's so much stuff that will
have incrementally improved during early
access
but we're also keeping certain surprises
for the ending for the release itself
so it will be i hope a big step-up and a
positive one that will be welcomed by
everybody uh because we do have a bunch
of stuff
upper sleeves even if we've had some
leaks uh
so um and then the second
so the second quantum jump should be the
final update and under
the release version so that's uh
certainly the intention
uh of what we're trying to do but i mean
like
the the difference between bg3 and those
uh
is that this game is vastly more complex
to make
it is in every aspect much more
ambitious and everything that
that it covers uh so when we'll
pull it all together and actually pull
off releasing it
i'll uh yeah i would already be happy if
it didn't have to do that quantum jump
and that's gonna come on top of it so
it's gonna be
it's gonna be quite something very cool
to dungeons and dragons and something
that dos two had was the dungeon master
mode you've not really spoken about it
much
in the past is that something you can
talk on now
no because we we honestly we don't have
it in development everybody asks that
question but we
are so focused on making the game itself
and it's such a beast
to develop that we just the company has
more than tripled in size
to make vg3 and even then worse if you
look at the recruitment page you see
there's plenty of jobs
openings and this is just because we
it's so
hungry as a game and every single asset
is being
delivered at such a high level of
quality and that um
yeah we just don't have the room at this
point
it's a um obviously this would be a
setting which would really benefit from
it right
uh but uh yeah for us really the thing
that matters is
getting the game going getting it
finished so that when you play it and
when you replay it or when you talk to
your friends about it you
hear hey but my adventure was completely
different and you're gonna say yes of
course it is because you made different
decisions
uh so that's really what we're trying to
build and that's
uh yeah that's quite the endeavor for uh
already
so is the dungeon master mode something
you might look at doing post release or
i honestly everybody right now is
focused on just getting vg3 done
uh and like uh the fact that that is
still on an
uncertain horizon in the future tells
you how much work we still have
and if you see how we've grown how much
people are working out there and
passionately on it
it also tells you exactly how how much
it is
uh so because um like
it just were this very original sin it
was done already
like over we made two resources already
with the amount of stuff that we're
putting in there uh so it's just a um
and it's not that it's that much longer
in content it's just that the
permutations and the the intensity with
which each
little minute of gameplay is being
worked on is so high
and the ambitions of the team they're
super passionate about it so there's so
much love that they're putting into it
and trying to
um i i you know i like beaches in my
games right so
when you play the uh
so i also start up on the beach because
it's the beginning of act one once
you've skipped the tutorial
and uh that [ __ ] keeps on getting
better you know every single time i look
at that beach when you look at the early
access beach day one and now
that beach is so much better and i know
it's coming so like that beach is gonna
be so much better still and it's just
the beach
there's actually a big surprise on the
beach in the next update i can tell you
that
depending on the choice that you made
and then the tutorial which has changes
and so forth
so and those things and you you when you
look at it you'll wonder
why would they do all the effort of
putting that in there and that's yeah
well i mean it makes sense and there's
all the players that ask for it so
we put it in there and then and when you
see what it is you say okay but the
ramifications of these are pretty large
uh so and yes they are pretty large so
we'll put it through
the entire game and so this is uh and
then when you play it and that's what
you discover you say hey i'm happy that
somebody cared enough about this
particular path
to see it to definition so that's all
there just me
and the other two people in the world
will see this but we're happy that
somebody cared about doing this and
that's that's the bit where all the
intent
and the effort goes into and the things
that you will never see
but when you see them you're happy that
somebody puts love and care into them
people are going to go back to that
starter beach now and try to
figure out what exactly you're teasing
here they'll know they'll know
they'll figure it out well they'll
figure it out i mean like it's uh
maybe on the next time when we chat you
ask me okay well you remember when you
said that
and then i'll tell you exactly how many
permutations this thing cost so
the list and the documents the amount of
meetings because i was president a
couple of them and the the amount of
people that were really working on for a
long time
just to make this possible it's like uh
every single time we use
this is the thing with this game you're
always surprised by how much work every
single thing is just because of
this approach that we're taking with it
and trying to sustain it
cinematically also throughout the entire
thing right so
it's a um yeah it's a it's an amazing
thing
the minute-to-minute gameplay that in an
rpg doll in the way that we're doing it
takes a lot of effort and you don't want
to compromise on it because you're doing
the cinematics which is the thing that
that people forget um because it's much
easier
if you make an rpg like we used to make
and just adding a couple of lines
hey here's a new branch and a guideline
let's just go and put it in there no
now it needs the entire enchilada that
comes with putting it
cinematically in there and uh and
multiplayer in single player
uh depending on which characters which
party member composition and support and
support you know
and uh
and i'm very happy every single time
when i see this okay i'm really happy
that
they spend time on doing this like this
it feels good but it is
i keep on repeating it because it is it
is a lot of work so it's been a while
since you've had the community's ear
but you've got it now you've got the
floor is there anything you want to say
to your hungry fans
uh it would be
[Music]
hang in there like
it's we are passionate about making this
a really really good game
a really good rpg that we can be very
proud of and that you are gonna love
playing
that is going to respect your choices as
a player uh but to be able to deliver
that
we need time uh so um
i i know that there's a lot of people
that are impatient and they want us to
but we can't we can't just cram out the
content like that we do need
uh for content that we can be proud of
we need time to
trade over it and we don't want to
present it just like
uh here's a bunch of grinding quests go
and fetch me five shoelaces so that you
can uh
we're never gonna do that uh so
but that takes time to do it the other
way and so
hang in there honestly i think the most
thing i see on the balls gate 3
subreddit is just wanting you in armor
again anyway
but hopefully it won't be too long now
until we can see both you and arma
and more of boulder's gate 3 until then
everyone at home for more boulders gate
3 news and updates whenever we can get
them
make sure you subscribe to gamespot
[Music]
you